I want to take a moment to say thank you to everybody who makes the podcast possible.
That's scoutmastercgcom, backers and patrons. You can join them. It's easy to do: Just go to
scoutmastercgcom and click the support link at the top of the page. Here we go. And now
scoutmaster
Troop 38 in New Berlin, Wisconsin, was out camping on the shore in Door County And they were sitting
down at dinner getting ready to eat the sausages that they had cooked over the fire And this fellow
strides into their camp And under his arm he has one of the native shorebirds and he
offers to trade it for one of those German sausages that the scouts had prepared.
And they said, yeah, why not? And that, as you may imagine, was the day that Troop 38
took a turn for the worst. You work on that for a little bit And if you need to have that
explained to you, I'll send you to Matt Weiss, who shared that little story with me. He's the
Scoutmaster Troop 38 in New Berlin, Wisconsin. Thank you, Matt, I think. hey, this is podcast
number 359..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
Quick reminder before we get going here today, we'll have a podcast next week, a special holiday
podcast next week, by the way, And then we'll be off for a couple of weeks during the holidays.
We'll be back next year with the beginning of a series of podcasts about the foundations
of scouting. I think that's what it'll be called the foundations of scouting, or
something like that. Today, I have a thought for you that addresses one of the things that
I get asked about very frequently. I see a lot of emails about the subject of discipline in a scout
troop, And it's something that we talk about fairly often. As a matter of fact, we talked about
these principles a couple of three podcasts ago when scouts misbehave. I'll link to that in
the podcast notes, as well as to an article that I linked to in that other podcast, which is
constructive scouting discipline, And I don't mind repeating myself. It's an important subject
we are sure to deal with, And it's one that is not all that easy to figure out. So let's get started,
shall we?
So here's a tale of two troops. Pretty dramatic, huh? Just imagine you've got two troops, troop A
and troop B. Both troops have average scouts. whatever average means who do what average scouts do?
They're pretty much the same troop. Now, both troop A and troop B have a well-defined
procedural approach to discipline and misbehavior. Troop A publishes a guide that defines the rules,
how those rules are enforced and the penalties for breaking those rules.
Troop B does not have a guide. They have no written rules, So they don't really have any
defined measures for policing the rules And they don't have any defined penalties for breaking
the rules. For the purposes of illustration, let's pretend an average scout in troop A
decides to misbehave in precisely the same manner as an average scout in troop B. They both do exactly
the same thing. Now, exactly what that thing is isn't really all that important to the story,
but the nature of what they've done, the way that they've misbehaved,
it's reasonably serious. It's serious enough for everybody to take notice of and to deal with.
Now the scouts from troop A. they refer to their guide, They figure out what rule has been broken
and they follow the prescribed penalty for breaking the rules, which is because it's a fairly serious
problem. The scout is suspended for the next two months. The scouts from troop B sit down
with the scout, They counsel him, They speak with his parents. The scout apologizes ultimately
and promises not to misbehave in the same way again. But a month later the scout from
troop B misbehaves in the same way again. So the scouts get together, they counsel with the scout,
they talk to his parents and everyone agrees he'll have to forego actively participating with
the troop until he and his parents have figured out how to assure everyone that he's not going
to continue to misbehave. Two weeks after that discussion the scout comes back to troop B
with his parents. They assure the scout that they've addressed the misbehavior and it won't
be repeated. Meanwhile, two months after the first incident from the scout in troop A,
he's pretty much decided he's not all that interested in scouts anymore. but his parents
are going to make him go back, as parents probably should do, and he misbehaves in the same way
And the scouts from troop B look at their rulebook. They figure out that he's broken the
same rule twice. They look at their disciplinary rules and the scouts kicked out of the troop
permanently. But the story doesn't end there, because his parents decide that this is unfair
and unjust and they make a stink about the whole thing and it consumes a lot of emotional real
estate and a lot of time And it's really another few months before the whole issue
is finally out of everybody's mind and settled. Meanwhile, back in troop B. our typical scout
is moving on. Now. he's no angel, He's not an easy customer. He requires a lot of talking
and discussing, but he manages to stay involved with his troop. Now remember what I said:
Both troop A and troop B have an equally well-defined procedural approach to discipline
and misbehavior. And I told you that troop A has a guide with rules and enforcements
and penalties. So what is troop B's procedure? Well, troop B has no written rules,
so they measure the conduct of their scouts against the scout oath and law. When a scout in troop B
misbehaves, a discussion follows and in the discussion the scouts ask what points of
the scout oath and law apply to the situation. If the misbehavior is serious enough,
the scout's parents will be brought into the discussion, made aware of the circumstances,
so they can take any action that they may choose to take. And since troop B has no rules,
they don't have any need to police the rules or predetermined penalties for breaking them.
So there's no punishments, There's no suspensions, There's nothing. There's nothing like that,
And this tends to make the atmosphere in troop B a little lighter than it is in troop A,
Since every scout and every circumstance is different. troop B responds to problems
on a case-by-case basis. Troop B does recognize the difference between a single
instance of misbehavior and a pattern of misbehavior And they agree that if a scout has a pattern of
misbehavior they will consult with the scout's parents and tell them it's their responsibility
to take action to correct the problem before the scout can return to actively participating.
But hopefully the way that they deal with behavior on a case-by-case basis
makes that instance extraordinarily rare. Now, looking from the outside in,
troop A seems to be a more disciplined bunch. Troop B kind of seems lax and permissive
And if you think that you'd be wrong, If anything, the standards of behavior in troop B
are higher and more demanding than the standards of behavior in troop A.
If you have a list of rules and and enforcements and punishments, everything's pretty cut and
dried And that's not always, you know, a bad thing. But internalizing the ideals
of the scout oath and law is a lot harder. The expectations in that situation are much more
strict and much more effective. Both troop A and troop B have to find a way to bridge the gap
between expectations and experience. The expectation is scouts, according to the scout law,
are trustworthy, But our experience tells us that they often are not. So there's a gap between
our expectations and our experience and we have to bridge that somehow. The scouts in troop A decide
to bridge that with rules. It's a simple, well-defined way. They don't have to exercise much judgment
because the rules do it for them. The scouts in troop B end up doing a lot harder work,
especially emotionally, bridging the gap by applying the ideals of the scout oath and law.
Both of the troops definitely strive to create a safe environment of opportunities to live out
the oath and law. Troop B goes a little farther by leveraging the inevitable missteps, misbehaviors,
mistakes, failures into developing an internal standard of ideals based on the scout oath and law,
because everything we need is in the scout oath and law. It addresses every situation. It's
simple and in nearly every scout has those things at least committed to memory. When your standard of
conduct and behavior is the scout oath and law, it's difficult to effectively argue your way out of
having misbehaved. When you misbehave and somebody sits down and calls you on it and says what part
of the scout oath and law apply to this, you have to think about it. You have to look inside,
You have to be honest with yourself and that utter honesty and transparency
that we approach these ideals with is not necessarily a familiar territory for scouts,
because in most other areas of their lives they have rules and enforcements and punishments.
It takes some bravery to have complete trust in scouts When you know by experience
they cannot be completely trustworthy and you can't breach that absolute trust
and lower your expectations. You have to assure that the environment they go scouting in is safe,
physically and emotionally. Yes, using the scout oath and law as a standard is not lax and not
permissive. It's just used in exchange for having sets of rules. And the great thing about
beginning with the very simple aspiration a scout is trustworthy is it opens up to us
a measured and compassionate approach to problems that are inevitably going to come along,
because the scout oath and law are broad enough and strong enough to be able to handle any
situation that we're given. That's my thought for this week. Like I said in the opening,
I think it's incredibly important. It bears repeating. Hopefully, the way that it was put
today in this podcast will be of some help to you. I'd love to hear your opinion.
You can get in touch with me. It's very easy to do And I'll tell you how to do that in just a moment.
Thank you for listening to this 359th edition of the Scoutmaster podcast.
You can come and visit me right there at scoutmastercgcom, Use the contact form there or
just cut out the middleman and email me at clark at scoutmastercgcom. C-l-a-r-k-e
at scoutmastercgcom. Come and like us on Facebook and follow us on Twitter so you
know when we're going to be online for a live chat. Once again, thanks to our backers and our patrons,
and all the remains for me to do today is make sure you hear from our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you and good camping. Why? thank you, sir. Until next time, everyone.